this episode brought to you by
stamps.com why go to the store to get
stamps when you can have them printed
right at home for your convenience
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia good guy
remember it so you don't have to I want
to talk about the M&M characters why I'm
glad you asked audience represented by
late 80s Michael Keaton movie because
surprisingly not a lot of people do well
don't get me wrong the M&M characters
need no help getting noticed and them's
candies have been around since the 40s
but if you mentioned the brand name
today it's almost impossible not to
think of the funny distinct and
memorable characters they've been
associated with them for over 20 years
also make no mistake people do talk
about them at certain times after the
new Superbowl commercial that runs every
year their theatrical promos played in
several movie theaters their Christmas
ad that stayed the same for over 20
holiday seasons you could even turn
yourself into an M&M on their site for a
while these characters are as amazingly
popular now as they were when they were
first created but that's what people
don't talk about how were they created
who came up with the idea and how would
they be lasting for so long in doing
research I found there's actually not
that many sites discussing where these
icons came from I couldn't even find any
videos on it plenty on the candy brand
itself but not the characters at least
that I could find well you know what
there deserves to be
I know these characters exist just to
sell a product but we've had home movies
based on that premise and we got angry
when they weren't nominated for Oscars
just because they're used to sell
something doesn't mean they can't leave
a funny charming memorable impact we
know the personalities of these timeless
characters like we know Bugs Bunny or
Mickey Mouse characters he had almost 10
minutes at a time to get acquainted with
but with these guys he had only 30
seconds 30 seconds to make a connection
and we still feel like we know these
characters inside out that's something
that deserves to be explored so we're
gonna look over how these characters
came to be who they are and how they
entertained kids and adults for so many
years let's start at the beginning
Eminem's was created in the early 40s
and like any brand they utilized
advertising so they went through several
different strategies and spokespeople
they never had an official mask
that lasted for a long amount of time et
would have been perfect you both have
two letters and your names damn for the
closest thing they had to a long run was
putting faces and limbs on the candies
themselves something a lot of products
have done over the years though no
distinct personalities were formed they
did seem to focus on to a red plain one
and a yellow peanut one something about
those two colors and those two shapes
side by side seemed to be the most eye
pleasing in the mid 90s though sales
weren't performing as they wanted M&Ms
was not only becoming just another candy
both becoming one that was easily
imitated something had to be done to
make them stand out with a relatively
small budget they asked advertising firm
bbdo to breathe new life into them the
creative director at the time Susan
Credle knew they didn't have the ad
spend of other big clients like Coke or
Pepsi so they had to think simpler she
and her team came up with the idea of
giving the M&Ms personalities even
making them a little more adult so they
wouldn't just be associated with kid
stuff lucky enough they had the talent
of blue sky studios to animate them yeah
that blue sky studios and the campaign
began with different primetime
celebrities interacting with the red and
yellow M&M the tone was more laid-back
sophisticated show they didn't have to
always be bouncing around to be
entertaining you want one surely you
jest one bite no mangu here's lost we'd
help you find it
well I'm giddy you didn't notice what is
what what is she talking about it was a
totally different approach and people
seem to like it
well the commercials were a nice change
of pace everything changed when this
commercial premiered oh yes your
friendly neighborhood M&M the same M&Ms
that come in the back see once they act
as catching on rich milk chocolate on
the inside
yes oh that I'm really glad you came by
what is that because I'm all out kind of
use peanuts
hey I hear you delicious come on buddy
now you might be thinking what's the big
deal that just seems like the other ads
we saw but there's a couple things to
keep in mind one the M&Ms had a hundred
percent defined personalities red with
snarky egotistical and kind of a
backstabber yellow with laid-back
optimistic and usually clueless does not
only added more energy to the campaign
but also identities both kids and adults
could find funny second this is the
first time that guest celebrities to
voice them that's Jon Lovitz as red and
John Goodman as yellow who would both be
their voice actors for several more
commercials like Disney did with their
movies adults could now enjoy listening
to comedic talent they recognized thus
attach more interest in third this is
the definitive design that red and
yellow would have from this day on if
you look at the originals in black and
why you almost won't be able to tell
them apart but with these you definitely
could if a kid was to look at a coloring
book he could easily tell which one to
make red and which one to make yellow
and a la that's because they had the
creative genius of the late Will Vinton
yes Academy Award winning Will Vinton
founder of claymation creator of the
California Raisins animator of that
disturbing as hell mark twain movie
what's your name see the legend himself
though he's best known for stop-motion
he found him like trying out different
art forms and discovered he was really
good at computer animation so he took
his shot at this and I guess if you
really look at them you can't see the
resemblance to his other characters it's
no wonder the Eminem's almost seemed
cinematic as it was brought to life by
so much cinematic talent from there the
campaign was set up
take these easily identifiable
characters put them with us
ready and just let them interact off
each other the personalities of the two
were so cool or opposite you didn't need
much else thank you give me a break
so is it laughs yeah
Love Hurts it was simple it was funny
not too expensive and people remembered
it in fact the original idea was to have
several commercials running at a time
with a different celebrity in each one
but again costs were limited so they
would usually just pick one that had
good comedic timing and use them in
several continuing apps people like
Steven Weber Dennis Miller Tia Carrere
and my personal favorite Patrick
Warburton you're eating homonyms yeah
sorry you don't eat your own kind it's a
natural any food crispy amid the bags
well that's just disturbing nobody hears
the voices of the Eminem's would switch
out to read for example was replaced by
Billy West and yellow was replaced by JK
Simmons yep that JK Simmons who
apparently still voices him even to this
day but this was only the beginning for
the Kandi Koated family many more were
about to join the literal colorful cast
and much more good clean wholesome this
was on the way
[Music]
yeah it gets a little weird
[Applause]
[Music]
why I suddenly realize I need stamps I
will simply go to the post office and
get some goodness gracious no I hate
snow it prevents me from getting stay up
sweet angry what if I told you there was
a way that you could get stamps without
having to go to the post office
I'd say cabbage because I think that
word is funny but you see silly fool all
your problems can be answered by simply
going to stamps calm here's a slightly
less annoying voice to tell you about it
if you want to start off the New Year
with a resolution you can keep stop
going to the post office to send letters
and packages when you don't have to say
time the money this year by going to
stamps calm it's so handy when on days
like this the weather is really bad that
you can just print out your stamps right
at home whether it's mailing out
Christmas presents or letters or bills
or whatever I use it all the time
stamps.com is the faster and more
convenient way to get posted simply use
your computer to print official US
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
and the mail carrier picks it up no more
lugging mail to the post office no more
hassles stamps com not only saves you
time it saves you money too with dance
comm you get discounted postage rates
that you can't even get at the post
office not to mention a fraction of the
cost of those expensive postage meters
and there's no equipment to lease and no
long term commitments I use stamps calm
because it's convenient easy reliable
and efficient and right now you too can
enjoy the stamps comm service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
that's right a digital scale that you
can actually measure your packages with
so start the new year off right go to
stamps calm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
nostalgia vet stamps calm enter
nostalgia to get your four week free
trial stamps calm why travel to stamps
when Stan's can travel to you
you
[Applause]
with red and yellow going over so well
it only made sense to expand the M&M
family in 1995 a contest was held for
what would be the new M&M color the
results came in overwhelmingly blue this
all was decided they should give him a
personality to blue voiced then by the
late Phil Hartman was the only other nut
character though it alternates from
almond to peanut and at the time had a
plain version sidekick - he was the cool
guy everything went his way and red and
yellow were always extremely jealous
about how smooth he was this also made
him the most boring character you get to
dive into that big pool of milk
chocolate no no no you don't dive in
anymore insurance law so someone might
hit their head that make you wait in now
with a buddy Oh bummer
well one nut cracks a show it's kind of
like writing Superman or Mickey Mouse
it's just tricky to write for someone
who's supposed to be so perfect
there are certainly been examples of
people doing it very cleverly but blues
personality was only one joke he was
more successful than red or yellow this
is one of the reasons you don't see him
in many ads by himself
the last usually come from what red and
yellow think of them they're not blue
fester King atom one bites out with my
own eyes that's also one of the reasons
they drop the plane sidekick if they
couldn't even write one of them that
Grady can't really do too that great
still it's good to have an all-around
cool guy around I suppose sort of a
straight man to the strange antics funny
one catch on nearly as much as green
chocolate experience you then waiting
for green makes me think things things
God doesn't want me to think green
voiced by curry summer who I don't think
of that character take over the world
plot yet was the first female Eminem and
was made to promote the dark chocolate
mint or peanut butter brand her main
thing was she was the sexy one because
deviantART is writing commercials now
well my new movies opening and no Dennis
I don't remove my shell of course not so
I'll be honest at first I didn't really
like green because back then whenever a
girl entered an all-boys Club she was
either forgettable or just the sexy one
looking back though she's actually not
as bad as I remember first of all she
does have a personality she's kind of a
diva has a glamorous confidence too
but it's also pretty cynical honestly
I'd argue she has more personality than
blue secondly a lot of her character is
based around one big in joke in the 70s
an urban legend arose that green M&Ms
make you horny how why nobody explains
but let's be honest is that really the
craziest thing you heard from the 70s
there was even an ad that almost
straight-up addressed question sugar yes
true what they say about the Green Line
where do you get your gossip knowing
that starting out actually makes a lot
of this pretty clever and honestly a
sexy M&M is just funny to me it's
literally a circle and they play it off
it's like the most erotic thing in the
world it actually gives some really good
laughs especially when you see how
seriously some of the actors play it
it's whoa boys do
but he's my boy too his age I be
concerned of he wasn't interested it
allowed for a lot of surprisingly risque
jokes and do the characters credit
everyone stripped down at some point
usually on multiple occasions don't eyes
down nothing to see here correct once
again she actually gets funnier the more
I look back on her the next one on the
list is orange oh you're that new crispy
M&Ms guy huh are you trying to get me
killed
orange is my favorite character points
by Eric Hershberger orange represents
the crispy brand and the pretzel brand
his whole character is he's super
paranoid where the others are good at
smoothly avoiding being eaten he's just
freaked out by everything he's freaked
out about dying he's freaked out about
women he's freaked out that the pretzels
apparently gonna be shoved up his ass
all right let's get this over with he
just cracks me up
he's a total spaz every time I see him I
feel sorry for him what just makes me
laugh even more I'm feeling sorry for an
M&M could you just for one second put
yourself in my place
that's funny haha
there's your cousin Cheryl it's kind of
like those pigs you see advertising
barbecue wouldn't that became really
aware of what they were doing and they
just spiraled into a depressive episode
there's just something so bizarre lee
morbid about it that I can't help but
crack up he's definitely a keeper to
have around I don't know why everyone
wants to eat the crispy M&Ms I mean I
know I'm next Gabe brown or miss brown
because I work for her ya know the
others had titles before their names
alleged count white Eminem voiced by
Vanessa Williams and representing plane
and dark chocolate I almost feel like
she's a response to any hate green might
have gotten in the past cuz she's the
complete opposite while green as
fun-loving Brown is all business while
green as a wisecracker Brown tells no
jokes at all and while green loves being
sexy Brown is constantly pissed that
everyone confuses her for being naked
only a fool would think I'd actually
show up naked so it's that kind of body
I'm sexy and I know it she's so serious
she should do a detailed commercial
about her getting insurance I'm the
Geico gecko that happened
Geico only insures humans guess what day
it is save it humph boy just by being a
stick-in-the-mud she does get some good
laughs particularly at the expense of
the other evidence steer clear of
Kristen
she'll devour you really yeah thanks for
introducing us anything for a friend
she's a nice bit to the cast there's
been other side characters over the
years too there was a chocolate bar
which things would always go bad for it
because he would melt in the Sun get it
melts in your mouth and on your hand
he was also voiced by filler there's a
pretzel that sometimes oranges wingman
voiced by Maurice LaMarche and there's a
cube of caramel voiced by David Cross
who's always geeky they're gonna fix him
though by putting him in an M&M to stop
him being so square I know how lame that
is but they got David Cross the only
likable man in the elbe in the gym ugh
movies by god I have to give a pass on
this the characters are so relatable
that they don't even have to change the
commercials much when advertising in
other countries because the animation is
already done all they had to do is
change the people out and the light
is it more like gonna be was peanut he'd
I hear you delicious because my little
friend I've just run out which one of
yous peanuts here he's delicious
their popularity is so big they've
worked with pretty much everyone Danny
DeVito
Halle Berry the x-men Shrek Darth Vader
whoo
even keep at Meharry he's betraying his
skittle boombox
this is incredibly even admitted she
knew it would be a hit but to have an
M&M store based on the characters open
in Las Vegas and still remain open for
over 20 years was far beyond her
expectations and indeed the lasting
power of these characters probably went
beyond anyone's expectations at the very
least you hope your campaign will sell
more of a product but to create iconic
characters they're still beloved and
watched repeatedly on TV and YouTube is
something very rare commercials have
gotten millions of views before online
but there's so many compilations and so
many people both young and old who love
seeking them out it's not just one
commercial they like checking out it's a
ton of them not just because they're
funny but because the characters and
them are so likeable it's always
expected they're gonna have a Superbowl
ad every year it's always expected the
same Christmas commercial will play
every year and honestly I could go even
further in the theatrical promo
satirizing movie trailers they say we
don't make movies don't you
I would totally see that if Ernest Willy
Wonka uncle drew and Lego could get
their own successful movies why not them
the characters are already said they
work great off each other if the goddamn
Geico caveman could get their own show
yeah that's right Google that actually
don't these guys could work great in a
movie okay so it's a successful campaign
with successful characters why is that a
big deal
we've seen other product mascots last a
long time even longer than that in fact
well here's the thing
the M&Ms mascot combined three things
that I can't think any other product
mascot combines one there's some of the
few commercial characters they have
looked exactly the same for
over 20 years lots of characters last
for a while but they usually change with
the times
true at first they had to find their
fitting but within the year they got it
and once they had that definitive look
and personality they kept it exactly the
same for over two decades that rarely
happens - they're surprisingly fleshed
out characters even the best food
mascots like Tony the Tiger around
McDonald they're positive icons that
sell their products but they're not to
be dimensional enough to write a movie
or a show around these characters are
even though they're simple they're still
very human and you identify with them
very quickly and three there's some of
the only commercial mascots that kids
enjoy just as much as adults lucky is
great for children but not gonna do much
for adults
the Allstate guy gets a laugh out of
grown-ups but kids are really gonna be
sucked in by them
no matter what age though you laugh just
as hard at these characters enough
that's some celebrities who don't really
need to voice them out of necessity
anymore still come back to recreate
their roles every time even though they
were just created to sell a product they
still created characters that are kind
of similar to ones like Animaniacs or
looney tunes in fact a lot of M&Ms have
been even funnier than Looney tune adds
occasionally for having only 30 seconds
or less at a time they created some
clever timeless hilarious and even at
times kind of risque characters that
people enjoy watching around the world
I'm not saying these are deep complex
character studies or anything but they
are funny relatable and imaginative
icons in a field where only one of those
qualifications is needed their
commercials yeah but they're ones that
we rely on seeing every Christmas every
Super Bowl every time we need a good
laugh all I'm saying is a lot went into
making these characters a lot still goes
into making these characters and it's
worth showing how appreciative we still
are for that
[Music]
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember so
you don't have to
[Music]
hey everybody Doug Walker here we're
doing the end credits a little
differently cuz a lot of times people
don't wait through the credits they
don't watch it all and they miss the
charity shoutouts at the end so what
we're gonna do from now on we're just
gonna have the little logo at at the end
of the video and then we're gonna have
the credits play at the bottom and we're
just gonna jump straight to the charity
shout out and we're gonna make them a
lot quicker so you have a chance to
click on the link if you don't want to
you can click on other videos but we
highly recommend you go to these
wonderful organizations at least share
the link with other people if you can
donate but definitely raise awareness
because these are such good
organizations so with that said we're
just gonna go to our first one this
week's charities Give Kids the World
village this is an 84 Acre nonprofit
Resort in Central Florida that provides
week-long cost-free vacations to
children with critical illnesses and
their families the village and its
community partners provide children and
their families with accommodations in
fully furnished villas as well as
transportation tickets to theme parks
meals daily entertainment and so much
more this is a wonderful idea doing
wonderful things for wonderful families
definitely consider clicking on the link
and checking out all the good they have
to share and see if you can share that
good of right along with them
[Music]